la banda de marcha esté organizando una
rifa al finalizar el juego de americano
con dos premios después de que saquen el
primer boleto y lo pongan afuera de la
urna ese determinar a un ganador este
boleto se quedará afuera de la urna el
siguiente boleto que se saque
determinará el ganador del segundo
premio son los eventos independientes
explica antes de ver este caso
específico me gustaría que recordáramos
que son dos eventos independientes eso
significa que son eventos los cuales el
que pase uno no afecta que pase el otro
el primer boleto que se saca va a
determinar el primer ganador este boleto
se quedará afuera de la urna y después
se va a sacar un nuevo boleto de la urna
para determinar el ganador del segundo
premio ahora el ganador del segundo
premio es decir el evento de sacar el
boleto para determinar el segundo
ganador es completamente dependiente d
pendiente de quien ganó el primer premio
es decir del primer boleto que sacó
vamos a verlo con un caso particular
supongamos que existen solamente tres
boletos y vamos a suponer que la primera
vez que metemos la mano y sacamos un
boleto sacamos el boleto a por lo tanto
este va a determinar el primer premio
ahora para determinar a la persona que
va a ganar el segundo premio solamente
vamos a tomar en cuenta los dos boletos
restantes es decir el boleto b y el
boleto c y bueno de hecho podrá pasar de
otra manera por ejemplo vamos a pensarlo
y en este segundo escenario vamos a
suponer que la primera vez que metemos
la mano y extraemos un boleto es el
boleto de por lo tanto el boleto be
determina el ganador del primer premio y
por lo tanto los otros dos boletos
es decir el boleto y el boleto c son los
únicos que van a quedar en la urna para
determinar el ganador del segundo premio
y aquí ya se ve claramente que toda la
posibilidad que tenga el segundo evento
va a depender completamente de lo que
pasó en el 1er
por lo tanto estos no son eventos
independientes si quisiéramos hacerlos
totalmente independientes lo que
tendremos que hacer es dado que ya
sacamos el primer ganador del primer
premio es decir la primera extracción
del primer boleto vamos a sacar el
segundo boleto otra vez metiendo a este
boleto de nuevo en la urna es decir si
otra vez metemos los tres boletos en la
urna y esto implicaría entonces que el
ganador del primer premio podría ganarse
también el segundo premio es decir si
quieres que tus eventos sean
independientes pues de reemplazo
mientras que pasara lo contrario si tus
eventos son dependientes